I love this new pope he's so different I
don't even think he's Christian I heard
him giving a sermon he was like go to
church or don't you do you baby
hashtag whatevs people get upset at him
cuz he doesn't call out gays like well
the Bible says to hate gays he's like
does it I have not read it yet it's a
big book waiting for the movie to come
out where the gay football player come
out recently apparently he sat his
college team down told them he was gay
and they didn't tell anybody which is
fascinating
cuz very similar when I was in college
the football team sat me down and told
me I was gay and then told everybody
people say figure skating is the gayest
sport but I think it's football
think about it you these like muscular
men in tights trying to get on top of
one dude and this other group that's
like no stop he's ours you do something
wrong a man trots out and throws out a
colored flag
blows a whistle holding that's the
gayest penalty no time you can't hold on
to him you got to let him go
he's chasing after another man he's
going for the sack gay marriage it's a
hot topic it's very hot
it's flaming people are saying gay
marriage is gonna tear the moral fabric
of America that cuts deep because the
design of the fabric of America is being
used to oppress these people who are the
designers of the fabric of America I
can't judge I'm not a good person like
this is how you can tell if you're a
good person okay when you're on the
train you're on it
doors are open you see somebody just
like running down to catch that train in
your heart are you rooting
that they make it on whether the doors
slam in their face cuz I'll be honest in
my heart I'm rooting that they make it
on and then the doors closed and then
they look up and realize it's the wrong
train whenever I complain about the
Train though some girl will chime in a
bit first of all problems first of all
problems but I live in the first world
if you live in the first world then a
first world problem is just a problem
it'd be insane if I was complaining
about third world problems right a
Facebook post I was like OMG caught
malaria again what what is wrong with
you FML ran out of drinking water how
get your life together lost a limb
during hashtag tribal warfare no you
live in America you don't lose a limb
in fact you gain a chin because growing
up my parents that always tell me
make sure you marry an Indian girl make
sure you marry an Indian girl but I'm
attracted to all woman black white tall
short skinny really skinny it doesn't
matter so when I started dating a white
girl my friend suggested the way I break
it to my parents tell them I'm gay then
when I tell them I'm straight they'd be
so relieved that I don't to borrow an
Indian phrase eat the banana from both
ends
that they wouldn't care that she's white
so I went to my parents said mama Baba
I'm gay my dad he looked at my mom he
looked at me said we already knew that
he said the football team told us
said just make sure you marry an Indian
boy
you